until fifty years ago only men were
allowed to attend the White House
Correspondents Dinner and after Michelle
Wolf's cringefest performance on
Saturday night the Correspondents
Association is considering reinstating
that rule we will analyze why Wolf's
stick bombed the difference between
comedy and important comedy and why the
left can't tell jokes these days then my
latest video for Prager you on leftist
abuse of language somebody get it to
Kanye
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so there's a lot to get to today it is
also I didn't mention this at the top
it's the seal Richards as last day at
Planned Parenthood she's the maniacal
ghoul who has run Planned Parenthood for
a decade and I'm sort of sorry to see
her go I'll explain why we'll also play
the audio of my new preggers you video
at the end here mostly because I really
want Kanye to see this Kanye is now on a
run of Scott Adams Jordan Peterson
Candice Owens I think this is the time
for him to see my fragrant
it's about language it's about if you
how you can if you control the words you
control the culture so you know go find
it on YouTube tweeted it Kanye I'd
really appreciate that we're really
really trying to expedite his process in
political transformation here before we
get to these things cuz we I'm I want to
analyze this Michelle wolf thing bit by
bit
there's a ton of fake news about it
everybody's lying to themselves nobody
thought it was funny we will explain why
I actually know why her shtick failed
before we get to that we have to talk
about a new sponsor and one of the
coolest sponsors ever this is little
bits little bits is an award-winning
platform of easy to use electronic
building blocks for creating inventions
large and small this is without
exaggeration the coolest toy I've ever
played with this is I don't know if
you've ever seen these so they have they
sent me this this toy so I could play
around with it I'm supposed to send it
to my nephew which eventually I did you
know but I wanted to play around a
little bit first it is the complete
droid kit like the Star Wars droids six
bits 20 droid parts three sticker sheets
free app if this thing existed when I
was a kid I would have died for it it is
so and I so they send me the thing and I
say okay I'll give this to my nephew I
think he'll really like this you know I
I'm just sitting here in my studio the
office floods in twenty eight year olds
30 year olds asking me if they can have
this toy literally trying to take this
toy from a child I said no absolutely
not but it is really really cool even
adults like this thing it's so it's got
this app with step-by-step instructions
and video tutorials it's kind of like
you know you can you build it up and
then you kind of program and it's really
really cool it's got drive mode force
mode self navigation 20 authentic droid
sounds from Star Wars films
you can reconfigure it in different ways
you can create new droids 22 missions in
the app to teach their droid new skills
you can customize new ones give them
personality it's also a great way for
kids to learn how to code so there is
this educational element but it's really
really cool kids learn to control the
electronics with code in missions it
does require a smart device so you do it
all from your phone so so cool my so I
said I sent this over to my nephew he is
so excited I didn't realize you know I'm
not in the toy culture that much this is
like the thing to have you have to get
it
little bits he is he is truly ecstatic
about it
so visit right now don't say I never did
nothing for you visit little bits
dot-com slash Noel's Kano wles just like
jay-z's wife you will get $10 off a
droid inventor kit buy it it's the
coolest thing ever get it now for
Christmas this is really the hot toy it
is so cool I was like a real Star Wars
nerd as a kid if this toy had been
around when I was a kid I would have
been insufferable for my parents get the
toy associations 2018 toy of the year
for your kids and inspire invention you
know in Christmas and the holidays come
around you never know what to get kids
get this get it right now and you'll
save $10 little bits comm slash Noel's
ko wles $10 off a droid inventor kit
okay so the White House Correspondents
Dinner was on Saturday they call this
nerd prom and by they I mean the people
who go no one else calls it nerd prom
that like regular people don't call it
nerd prom and it isn't nerd prom this is
so absurd this is so self-aggrandizing
it's all these you know journalists and
bloggers and TV types and they call it
nerd prom because what they're saying is
we're really smart
it's nerd prom because we're so we're
nerds so we you know we put on our
tuxedos and you're not nerds nerds are
smart brian Stelter and Don Lemon and
Jim Acosta are not nerds they're they're
dummies I'm sorry to say I don't want to
be mean to you guys I don't but you're
not nerds you can't call yourselves
nerds you look good on TV
at least Jim Acosta does you know you'd
up but you're not nerds like Jim Acosta
just the I think the height of his
intellectual Act
he is staring at himself in the mirror
and smiling that is what Jim Acosta does
so that this happened on Saturday a ton
of backlash against the main performer
so the White House Correspondents Dinner
has been going on since the Coolidge
administration and they they would
always have some sort of entertainment
some celebrities would show up
Sinatra started going in the 70s and by
I think it was 1985 that was the first
year they invited a comedian to give the
monologue at this event now that you
know these have been going on for a long
time they had some good ones in the
early 2000s Norm Macdonald came he was
great Darrell Hammond came even Stephen
Colbert pushed the edge a little bit but
he was still fine
this woman bombed I mean it was really
awful it she totally bombed and now some
people are trying to defend her and say
it was good even though really no one
thinks that the view leave it to the
view here are the ladies at the view
defending Michelle Wolf's monologue I'm
sorry that was just a bunch of cackling
hyenas do we can easy to confuse do we
have the clip of the view stop putting
tell you in on your shows all she does
is lie it's like that old saying if a
tree falls in the woods how do we get
Kellyanne under that tree
suggesting she gets hurt just stuck I
actually really liked Sarah I think
she's very resourceful like she burns
fats and then she uses that ash to
create a perfect smoky eye like maybe
she's born with it maybe it's lies so
did she go too far well when I first saw
the coverage of it cuz I hadn't seen it
live I thought that someone had really
pushed the limit because every headline
was it was awful it was uncomfortable
then I read it and watched the clips and
she the comedian did her job she is
there to come and push the envelope
that's what comedians do right if people
have problem with it it might be taking
issue with this dinner result as a whole
in these times no that isn't true that
isn't her job that isn't her look there
have been plenty of comedians on I guess
they're all on the left some are not
quite on the left but they're usually on
the left and no one's taken any issue
with them even Stephen Colbert who
really actually did kind of go up to the
edge but that isn't their job the job of
a comedian is not to push the envelope
the job of a comedian is to be funny
that's the only job of the comedian and
this gets I had owned Benjamin on the
show a few weeks ago and he talked about
this big distinction in comedians the
ones who go for claps not laughs the one
like Jimmy Kimmel can't be funny anymore
because the left lost its sense of humor
so now instead of telling jokes on his
show
instead of making people laugh he makes
political statements and then they don't
laugh because it isn't funny so they
just clap they clap approving ladies Wow
yeah hmm he said he said a thing mm yeah
it doesn't didn't tickle me because he's
not doing his job but mmm you know it
this is the distinction between comedy
and important comedy that's that this is
the main distinction in comedians these
days because there are comedians who
make people laugh and they tell jokes
and then there are people who can't make
them others laugh who can't tell jokes
so they do important comedy this kind of
ruined George Carlin even when he had
decided to become a philosopher instead
of a comedian
very talented comedian and then he
started doing this philosopher stick it
isn't great it isn't what comedy is for
and but people totally misunderstand the
job of comedians they say you're there
to speak truth to power no that's what
journalists are there for hey totally
derelict to their duty for a decade and
now they are there the butt of jokes and
now they're sort of the clowns rather
than the the journalists or the
comedians and the comedians are there to
make people laugh
so I'm not surprised that the view isn't
the most insightful place to look for
commentary on this the left and
anti-trump conservatives now are calling
those of us who didn't like the shtick
hypocrites they're saying oh what are
you offended snowflakes or you know
you're always saying we're offended now
you're offended it's not quite that I'm
offended I am offended because it's not
a good taste but what I don't really
care it's just that it isn't funny and
the set bombed everyone admits that the
set bombed even the left admits it this
isn't some left right thing the left
admits it bombs Douglas Brinkley the
who's a CNN talking head who refers to
himself as a presidential historian
Douglas Brinkley came on for reaction
after the Correspondents Dinner and they
said what do you think and he said well
you know there were some good lines
right he's trying to put a good spin on
it now there were a couple of good
liners and then they brought him on
again he said well yeah I mean well
yikes
and then they're done they brought him
on he said okay they got to cancel this
dinner this was a disaster Margaret
talev
the head of the White House
Correspondents Association she defended
wolf she called
wolf a talented comedian who had a
message to deliver and she did deliver a
message again you're getting this back
to the views misunderstanding of comedy
the point of comedy isn't to deliver a
message it's to make people laugh so
then the head of the White House
Correspondents Association said
unfortunately the entertainer's
monologue was not in the spirit of that
mission to unify the country so even the
White House Correspondents Association
through this woman under the bus Maggie
Haberman criticized it Maggie Haberman
more than basically any journalist was
totally in the tank for Hillary the
Hillary campaign openly talked about
this with one another in memoranda that
since come out but Maggie Haberman
tweeted out she said that the press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders sat and
absorbed intense criticism of her
physical appearance her job performance
and so forth instead of walking out on
national television was impressive is
that michelle wolf was really crude to
the to President Trump and then almost
explosively the women in the Trump
administration those were her two
targets Trump and the women in the Trump
administration now I have to say a lot
of this sends alike a little too little
too late because everybody was laughing
in the room I don't know that it was
like real laughter but it was at least
performed laughter all of those
left-wing journalists there they they
gave her her laughs they played into
some of the bits some you know she did
this thing well we'll get to it in a
little bit
but she michelle wolf had this segment
where she would call out something and
then the whole audience would call back
so they were in it and then they
realized how awful it looked afterward
and i said okay we got to throw her
under the bus we've got to throw wolf
under the bus because wolf was vulgar
she was vicious to women about their
appearance
she was profane she was and and what all
of the media people realized because
they were all laughing in the room but
then when they left they said uh-oh
now we can't criticize Trump for those
things uh-oh
yikes we just destroyed our main line of
attack against Donald Trump oh yeah that
was really bad we hate heard yada yada
yada so in that way I think it was
really a great event because it showed
them to be the hypocrites that they are
so the other ridiculous lie that's going
around is that wolf mocked everybody
look she mocked everybody only the GOP
is getting offended you little
snowflakes but she mocked everybody the
Twitter description of the trending
story of the White House Correspondents
Dinner written by Twitter said wolf
doled it out to everybody
wolf start everybody NBC analyst Howard
Fineman wrote about this he said he
tweeted out regarding Michelle wolf one
yup crude blunt pitiless remind you of
say a president hmm number two
she torched everyone even Democrats
stormy Daniels the media 3 she wasn't
playing to all of America or the room
but to her Netflix deal for she was
invited 5 it's not her job to behave and
6 she's funny
basically none of that is true or if
it's true it shows that she was terrible
number 1 right he admits here that this
was more about attacking the president
than being funny they just want their
out for blood they want to attack the
president so that wasn't it was about
attacking the president right number two
that's a lie the few jokes that she told
about Dems were compliments they were
you know this is I think they called it
Ben smithing after the founder of
Politico her after the founder of
BuzzFeed I suppose he been smithing is
when you say something mean about
Democrats but it's just mean enough to
get credibility as an attack but then
it's not so mean that it actually hurts
so one of the jokes that michelle wolf
said was democrats are bad because they
lose sometimes you know they're really
bad because they lose elections the the
whole joke was you know republicans
could nominate jeff pedophile not see
doctor and the democrats would still
lose so the whole joke is democrats are
great and the only flaw is that i don't
know they're not charismatic enough but
they're really good
another joke was that rachel maddow is
just too smart for TV she Oh Rachel
Maddow is way too educated for a popular
TV show haha
that's the Jets not a insult that's not
an attack so then number three that the
NBC analyst says is [ __ ] I mean she
didn't do her job she didn't if she's
playing to all of the playing to all of
these places other than the room then
she didn't do her job it you know yes he
says number four she was invited but
that was that was a mistake to invite
her you know it's it's not her job sure
it's not her job to behave but it is her
job to read the room and to entertain
which obviously she did not do obviously
the reaction shows she did not do her
job and she isn't funny she isn't funny
she just makes political statements that
this guy at NBC likes but that's not the
same thing as being funny there were
plenty of people who on the conservative
side who say things that I like who
aren't funny then that's good I like
them but it doesn't make them a comedian
now the final left-wing attack here is
that it is hypocritical for Trump
supporters to attack this woman for
being vulgar and profane and not having
class or anything and not being funny
they say it's hypocritical because trot
you know Trump says mean things and he
says vulgar things and all that I will
explain to you why these cases are
completely different here is a classic
example from Donald Trump from one of
the debates with Hillary Clinton oh it
is it's just awfully good that someone
with the temperament of Donald Trump is
not in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in jail Secretary
Clinton that is a very funny line that
shows a quick wit it wasn't scripted he
what you know Michelle wolf was reading
from her script all night but that was
extemporaneous very quick wit now if
Michelle wolf were to try to do a joke
like that she would probably just yell
in that nasal voice you're a criminal
that's what she was saying all night you
lie you're a liar you lie and says
you're a criminal but that's not funny
what what's funny is waiting for Hillary
to tee it up and then Hillary says I
don't want to live in an America where
Donald Trump is president so how do you
play on that well why not one you could
make a joke about her character her own
actions and you could make a joke about
what happens if you're president right
you play around in this scenario a joke
requires detachment it requires space so
he says she says I don't want to live in
an America with Donald Trump it's not
like he says yeah that's right you
wouldn't you know because I'd do good
things and you would do bad things when
we went right that would be the Michelle
wolf thing said he goes yeah you'd be in
jail that's why that's why you wouldn't
like is you're a crook that's funny and
that's tit he's detached enough to enjoy
it he's having fun up there he's not
just very angry he did this with
everybody he did it with Rand Paul he
did it with Maher little Marco to use
his phrase and of course he did it to
Jeb Bush here is an an amazing one from
Jeb this is
tough business you're a tough guy Jay
and it's and we need to have a leader
that is good real tough you're never
gonna be President is open your way to
let's see I'm like 42 and you're at
three says hey I'm doing bad doesn't
matter you know you started off all the
year Jeb you're moving over further and
further pretty soon you're gonna be off
the end devastating devastating and and
the reason that's so funny well the main
reason it's so funny is because it's
true Jeb Bush says you got to be real
tough like me and so what is Trump do he
doesn't say you're not tough I'm tougher
I'm Robert righty that's what Michelle
wolf would do instead he just points out
the obvious he say oh yeah you're real
tough you know you're a big tough guy
I'm real net right it said if you just
prick that little ridiculous balloon
it'll pop because we all know what the
truth is the other reason it's funny is
that he's punching back he isn't really
starting these fights
Roseanne Roseanne Barr was tweeting all
of the rules for comedy to explain why
this shtick didn't work at the
Correspondents Dinner and one thing she
said is never insult someone in the room
who's more famous than you never pick a
fight with someone more famous than you
because you'll lose the audience and
Donald Trump actually doesn't really
pick fights he tends just to hit back he
did this with Rosie O'Donnell he did
this with Jeb Bush he did this with
Hillary on and on he with Rosie you
someone he was so vicious with her but
he said look with me she insulted me she
insulted my business and so with me I
fight back and so it actually makes him
the underdog Jeb Bush in in these
attacks Hillary Clinton they were the
they were the supposed to be the bigger
characters they were supposed to be the
more stately people but they degraded
themselves and they kept attacking and
attacking so tried just gave Trump the
opening to punch back even with John
McCain you know he was so vicious to
McCain and basically made fun of his
being a prisoner of war but McCain did
start it he didn't now I'm not saying
McCain was this vicious to Trump he
wasn't but he criticized Trump and what
happens with Trump is the minute you hit
him he punches you back at least twice
as hard you can argue about whether
that's appropriate or nice or whatever
but it's always punching back the other
about Trump is as calmly isn't
essentially angry if it plays on anger
sometimes but it's actually not angry in
itself it might be affect simile of
anger but it's not really anger here's a
great example of this so I get a call
from one of the reporters yesterday and
they said the President of Mexico said
they will not under any circumstances
pay for the wall what is your comment I
said the wolf just got ten feet higher
now if he were really angry he knew
there wouldn't be a joke there he
wouldn't know how to play on their it
reactions right he'd say you're not
gonna believe what they said to me but
they're not gonna get away with this
because da da da button you did this to
me right now and that would be the
Michelle wolf response but the Trump
response is okay they've thrown this one
at me I'm gonna detach myself a little
bit how can i oh yeah
that's a funny joke the wall just got 10
feet higher and goes right and that's
why it's funny
the washington post where democracy dies
in darkness ran a troll ish headline
today because her performance is
basically being universally condemned
but they ran the headline they said
Michelle wolf got it just right
this is how the piece goes that Wolf's
performance was not normal for the
Correspondents Dinner is a testament to
its timeliness and necessity nothing is
normal right now so that's what this is
important comedy that's what this is
it's not we need to suspend the rules
because it isn't normal this isn't stop
it this isn't normal this is why
left-wing comedy is so insufferable
they're all doing this they're doing
this important comedy so if you know if
the purpose of comedy is to make people
laugh then they'll keep they'll keep
that in mind
but they say no these are nor these
aren't normal times we have to suspend
all the rules no you don't you don't
have to suspend all the rules you're
you're just you're in this vacuum you're
your vision is so warped by your own
hatred of Donald Trump that you don't
realize the rules of comedies still
apply and so you might you might find
catharsis in her saying mean things
about Trump that's not comedy let's get
to Michelle wolf herself to compare so
the woman who introduced her said
Michelle wolf is not a political
comedian by trade and that is obviously
true she clearly isn't it's why she
bombed it so badly here's how Michelle
wolf opens like a porn star says when
she's about to have sex with the Trump
let's get this over with
yeah this is you're getting tonight I'm
gonna skip it a lot of the normal
pleasantries we're at a Hilton it's not
nice this is on c-span no one watches
that Trump is president it's not ideal
the White House Correspondents
Association thank you for having me the
monkfish was fine
so that's how she opens she opens up
with this very easy joke about a
pornstar right and she and referring to
Trump just Trump right not President
Trump not the sitting president just
Trump a very it immediately begins with
disrespect and an easy joke a joke that
anybody could make and she addresses
that she said this is not going to be
nice everything about this is not nice
right now it's supposed to be this
glitzy affair black-tie you know that
these journalists get to go out for a
night and pretend that they're movie
stars or celebrities there so it is
supposed to be elevated and a little
glamorous that's been the way it's been
for decades and decades it's a charity
dinner so it's but she says no this
ain't gonna be nice I'm gonna make this
unpleasant and tense and debased and
ugly and just bad right and so you're
already know where she's coming from
she's not coming from a healthy place
she's not coming from the kind of place
where you would laugh and tell jokes
she's saying this is a miserable time
and you're gonna be miserable with me I
identified 48 statements that she
intended to be jokes because I watched
the whole thing I watched it as parts of
it a few times and I was able to
identify 48 lines that she would
probably call jokes they weren't quite
jokes I say that the the Oxford English
Dictionary definition of a joke is a
thing that someone says to cause
amusement or laughter especially a story
with a funny punchline now forget that
these didn't really have punch lines a
lot of them a lot of the statements were
just statements they weren't jokes they
weren't intended to make people laugh
maybe maybe that she wanted people to
laugh but they they didn't follow the
arc of what an actual joke is so she'd
say so-and-so lies and is a liar what
so-and-so is a disappointment to women's
use that line a bunch said yeah Ivanka
Trump is a disappointment to women but
that isn't a joke that's just a an
insult but it's not an it's not insult
comedy it's just you just don't that's
what you think okay that it's fine so
regardless I wanted to include that
because that that's 48 statements that
might have been intended to be jokes a
full 22 of them were a just about
genitals and a 23rd flew directly from
the genital to the scatological so 22 20
23 or
in below the waist and 22 were just
about genitals I'm I'm actually
surprised she did this because this sort
of thing is a parody of bad female
comedy this is what you get from Amy
Schumer when she's not stealing other
people's jokes and Sarah Silverman you
it's it it's the easiest grossest comedy
that usually people don't really laugh
at South Park perfectly skewered this
sort of fake comedy hey girls are funny
Wendy okay get over it just do witness
coming stuff you know talk about how fat
you are how you want to take a gadget
and say maybe yeah yeah that that is it
but is there Trey Parker and Matt Stone
are making fun of the Amy Schumer Sarah
Silverman kind of comedy because it's
that isn't funny I suppose they think
it's funny because it's incongruous
right they're playing on an incongruity
so they say well women are perceived as
being very feminine and nice and
pleasant and graceful and we're going to
be explicit and vulgar and materialistic
and profane but the thing is that
doesn't work any that only works once
that only works in the 80s it doesn't
work when the norm for women is feminism
when the gracefulness and the femininity
is all gone out the window for decades
then it's not funny anymore it's just
that's the way it is right that's sure
and now everything that Michelle wolf
did was extremely vulgar so f-words
explicit genital references pre raunchy
general references that's not to say
that you can't do those things you know
what you can talk like a sailor
sometimes or make jokes about genitals
or whatever but there is a time and a
place for that as I say there's a time
and a place for everything and that's
college but there are you know there are
times and places for this right so so
they'll say well Trump said gross things
he talked about genitals and made jokes
about genitals right he didn't do that
on a podium on a black-tie affair
he didn't even brag about it or do it in
public he defended those statements this
locker room talk because they were
locker room talk because he thought he
was having a private conversation with a
guy the sort of conversation that every
guy has sorry to tell you ladies
whatever whatever little feminist guy is
telling you I've never said anything
like that I've I've never done I've
never said anything so no and what
they're with
like run away because those are the
creepy guys that are convincing you that
they're nice and sensitive and feminist
and they are the creepiest of all those
are the Aziz Ansari types oh and and I
are discussing that they I think oh and
uses the word soy boy that run away from
that because that's locker room talk but
there's a difference between locker room
talk and glitzy Washington affairs
they're not you got to read the room you
got to read your crowd and also you've
all been criticizing Trump's for saying
those things so now you can't do it now
you've been saying it's O so what's the
worst thing he did that and yeah it's
great for her to do it cuz he did it
what that doesn't make any sense also
it's so easy to go blue in comedy it's
so easy to just cheat at comedy by using
swear words and raunchiness as a crutch
it's much easier to do that than to try
to do jokes without that Jerry Seinfeld
talks about this nor McDonald talks
about this it's much harder to be funny
without that crutch she wasn't even
playing on anything else it was just
raunchiness and bad words if you took
all of that out there wouldn't be any
words left there wouldn't be any and it
also isn't subversive so the idea is I'm
and that's the whole thing of like women
talking about their genitals I'm gonna
be subversive but that isn't subversive
that's the that's the way comedy is now
that's the the baseline that's the way
society is you hear it on network
television you hear little kids using
terrible words in front of their parents
little kids always use terrible words
they used to do it not in front of their
parents right now going clean is
subversive so there is a great again I
always bring up norm because he's the
best living comedian and nor MacDonald
was invited to one of these Comedy
Central roasts for Bob Saget and all of
these roasts was saying the same thing
as this just how do you say the
raunchiest grossest thing with the most
F words and so norm decided I'm gonna be
really subversive by telling clean jokes
from the Dean Martin roasts so you'd say
things like you know yeah you know your
face looks like a flower like a
cauliflower you know and Beyonce say oh
I've met this is so shocking this is so
subversive now the rest of the jokes
well have to wrap this up in a second
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube but
the rest of try to run through these
quickly the rest of them Hillary ignored
Segen in the campaign that was one of
the premises haha in another one
she michelle wolf called trump i'll just
say the word she called Trump a [ __ ]
now I can use it because they talk about
the hats that way and then she made a
joke about how she can't grab him haha
she used the euphemism about pulling out
of the Paris agreement and how most men
don't do that then one of her jokes just
said Trump is racist xenophobic Nazi
incompetent and impotent haha
just insults Tia she said teachers don't
need guns that was one of the premises
said Mike Pence is awful too and so this
was actually one of the best jokes of
the night she hit Mike Pence for being
pro-life that was the whole joke and it
hears I loved this joke here it is
Mike Pence is also very anti choice
he thinks abortion is murder which first
of all don't knock it till you try it
and when you do try it really knock it
you know you got to get that baby out of
it and yeah sure you can groan all you
won I know a lot of you are very
anti-abortion you know unless it's the
one you got for your secret mistress can
waiver but good for you this was
probably her best joke of the night one
of one of two that were passively funny
and the reason is there's not that this
joke was terribly funny it was pretty
horrifying it could it would have been
funny if it weren't such a horrifying
image that it kind of overwhelmed the
comedy of it but and obviously she
didn't get the room this was a totally
inappropriate joke for an event like
this but it was pretty good because it
killed all of the pro-abortion arguments
it actually did it sort of got to the
issue for instance she admitted that the
baby is a baby she said you got a really
you you know you've you've got to knock
it because you got to get that baby out
of there right she is saying look
abortion is when you take kill a baby in
the womb and get rid of it and she's
following that to its logical conclusion
so that is truthful she's kind of
playing on truth it's so horrifying it
wasn't totally funny but it was probably
the closest thing to a joke she had all
night she doesn't totally get the issue
but you know Jonathan Hyde did that
study that shows that
conservatives understand the left the
left doesn't understand the right
terribly well and then all the rest of
the jokes were about sex you know she
talked about how she worked at Bear
Stearns so she's never been harassed but
she got effed you know some easy jokes
like that one kind of funny one about
Myka and Joe
excuse me Myka and Joe where she said
Myka and Joe on Morning Joe on MSNBC
that it's always nice when I'm me too
works out it's kind of funny and the
rest just just total insults against
other media personalities so it doesn't
have to be this way the the the reason
the shtick bombed is because she's so
angry she hates Trump she hates the
Trump administration she hates the media
and so she would just call them liars
but calling someone a liar isn't a joke
and the premises other than the abortion
one we just weren't true she had a joke
about Starbucks and the premise was that
Starbucks isn't doing enough to stop
racial discrimination the real joke is
that Starbucks is the most hippie dippie
bleeding-heart place on earth and uh
there it isn't you know the Jim Crow
South
that's the that would be at the actual
joke it was so disconnected from reality
we will get into how it wasn't always
like this and had to get comedy back and
my Praeger you video but I got a sec
goodbye I'm sorry to Facebook and
YouTube you know you can find this show
on iTunes on stitcher on google on
facebook on youtube on myspace on xanga
on LiveJournal i think you can get it on
AOL Instant Messenger still if you text
that like chatbot I don't know I mean
this it's in a lot of places go check it
out go to daily wire calm right now for
the rest of the show you're really gonna
want to watch this and the preview video
but it's $10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me at the end will
claim and show you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag get them in that'll be on
Thursday you'll get to ask questions in
the conversation next one coming up
little ol me go to the Daily wire right
now none of that matters this is what
matters this this is what really matters
because listen I'm not willing when you
when you sip a delicious ambrosia you
don't always want to switch and right
now I'm on the the Kanye West vintage
2018 for when Kanye
West the biggest pop star in the world
decided that he was going to start
saying extremely conservative Republican
things on Twitter and the tears are
still flowing thank goodness I brought
this home over the weekend so that I
could survive some of my colleagues
sorry to say they perished they didn't
bring their leftist tears tumblers home
sorry don't don't be like them don't be
like them don't be caught unawares you
don't know the day or the hour when
leftist tears will drown you in their
salty deliciousness go to daily wire
comm we'll be right back
so it wasn't always like this it wasn't
always this vulgar in this crass and
this gross you know it wasn't always
this disconnected from reality at these
dinners I couldn't find a clip of
performers at these dinners because they
don't really have them available until
recently but here's a clip of President
Kennedy from the 1962 White House
Correspondents Dinner here's just an
idea of how it used to be like members
of Congress I have been during the last
few days over the Easter holiday back in
touch with my constituents and seeing
how they felt and frankly I've come back
to Washington from Palm Beach and I'm
against my entire program
[Laughter]
so that it's kind of funny too because
he john f kennedy's vacation home one of
his was right near donald trump's he
could go down to pump each a lot maybe
he went tomorrow lago who knows but as
it's just nicer the oscars used to be
nicer to the awards shows used to be
nicer because there was something called
a glamour and people say all the time
they say i miss it when politics was
civil
I hate Donald Trump because he's not
civil our politicians aren't civil if
you want the politics to be civil the
culture has to be civil if you want the
culture to be civil you have to be civil
you have to comport yourself with
dignity and integrity and not be
screaming and yelling and profane all
the time you know people can say they
tweet out or they put on Facebook you
know I effing hate this stupid whatever
Michelle wolf you know you're part of
the problem pal if you that's not the
sort of thing it is degrading to to
swear frequently in public
that's not something if you want things
to be civil and nice you have to behave
in a nice and civil way Roger Kimball
who is one of the great observers of
culture he got this exactly right at
American greatness he wrote quote the
idea that there is certain conduct
unbecoming a lady is anathema to
Michelle wolf on the contrary she wears
her vulgarity like a badge of honor
happy to trade an hour of embarrassed
titters for a lifetime of dishonor and
that's exactly right you go up and you
say I'm gonna get the applause of the
crowd for 15 minutes and I will
permanently degrade myself I will
permanently be that that woman who did
those disgusting things you know that
woman whose parents probably aren't very
proud of that display but I got the
titters of the crowd for an hour that
not not a good way to go through life
comedy doesn't have to be debasing it
can be witty it can be nice it can be
john f kennedy it can be Bob Hope it can
be plenty of good comedians it can be
Woody Allen for that matter but when it
becomes vile and mean and angry not only
is it debasing and not only is it does
it ruin the glamour and ruin the appeal
of that entertainment it isn't funny
work it actually works much better when
the performer and the audience have
dignity themselves okay we've got how
many more minutes do we have I got to
burn through these things huh I've got
all right well I want I really want to
talk about Cecile Richards and why I'm
going to miss her but I'll abbreviate it
Cecile Richards it's her last day
planned parenthood she's a total ghoul
but she strengthened the pro-life
movement she did we have a great debt of
gratitude to her her blood lust
increased abortions of Planned
Parenthood absolutely true but
nationally abortions decreased in 2014
abortion hit a historical low in America
fewer than a million abortions I know
that sounds terrible it's not like
damning with faint praise but that's the
right direction to be going down going
down it's her last day there she made
the goals of Planned Parenthood pretty
clear she was there to murder babies
that's her job and she took her job very
seriously she did her job very well but
we saw a lot of things come out of that
tenure there were those undercover
videos from the Center for medical
progress that showed members of Planned
Parenthood executives at Planned
Parenthood haggling over how much they
could get for selling baby parts and
organs and limbs illegally selling them
they were haggling over numbers and so
I'm gonna miss her I mean she was she
showed Planned Parenthood for what it is
and I hope the next person can be so it
cartoonishly ghoulish and I wish Cecile
Richards a nice time for the rest of her
days on earth before an eternity of
hellfire her wait sir okay I've got a
Prager you video out today this is about
how the left uses language and how they
destroy language so I'll just play a
little clip of it and you got to go over
and see it you got to share it and
really you've got to send it to Kanye
West
here's the video what's in a word why
does it matter whether we call someone
who breaks the law to enter the country
an illegal alien or an undocumented
immigrant what's the difference between
a Christmas tree and a holiday tree
it's just semantics right yes and no it
is just semantics but semantics means
the meaning of words words exist so that
we might discriminate
one thing from another without words we
have chaos and it starts with the first
ones a baby says mama to distinguish
mommy from daddy words shape how we
think they color how we view the world
no one understands this better than the
left they are the masters of words
because they know that words matter the
left has a special gift for you
familiarize so is to make those harsh
realities easier for us to swallow but
these soft words are insidious so
there's a lot more and if you aren't
watching right now if you're not a
subscriber the artwork is phenomenal on
this video they did an incredible job on
the artwork some people pointed out when
they talk about swallowing soft words
the Democrats give you it's a little
blue pill so well well done a little
Easter Egg if the video goes on for I
think another four minutes or so but
it's all it's so important it's a this
subtle point that a lot of people ignore
because it's so easy to get wrapped up
in the language of the left but language
is is where the battles are won it's
where the culture is one that's where
the politics is won the difference
between a Christmas tree and a holiday
tree is night and day the difference
between an undocumented worker or a
future American or a refugee asylum
seeker and an illegal alien that is
night and day totally shapes how we
think about subjects so please go over
there because really all I want is for
Kanye West to tweet this video I really
he's so close you know he's hanging out
with Candace Owens he's watching Jordan
Peterson videos he's watching Scott
Adams and I it's just the perfect moment
I think if we can get this in front of
Kanye it it'll be over it'll never take
that Magga head off so please tweet it
at him and send it to him and I hope you
enjoy the video let me know what you
think about it okay that's our show
we'll just have to get to the rest of
the news tomorrow
until then I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show I'll see you
tomorrow
the Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
forward publishing production executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by alex Zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jeshua of era
copyright for word publishing 2018